Finally here at our little news program
we love to look forward to the next generation of newsers.
And in that spirit, we have a very special guest.
She is a budding young journalist from Idaho Falls
who's becoming an internet sensation for her interviews.
She's interviewed her mom, her dad, her neighbors,
Keith Morrison, Lester Holt, Dr. Oz!
Oh my gosh!
She is a rising star and today, guess what?
Rossy we get to join that illustrious list.
I'm so honored.
Please welcome seven year old
behind the Seven Questions with Emmy,
Emmy Eaton!
Emmy!
(audience applauding)
Hi.
I'm so excited to be talking with you guys today.
Oh my goodness.
Emmy, you've done over 40 interviews
and you've got such a natural talent.
What is it about interviewing that you like so much?
I like that I get to talk
to so many people that are so amazing
and I love asking questions.
Do you do research?
Do you pick your subjects?
What's your process?
Well, I think of what they do.
Like if I were interviewing an author,
I would think, "Oh, what book did they write?"
And I would ask about that.
And if they wrote a fantasy, I would say,
"Okay, why did you want to write a fantasy?"
I love it.
Have you always been curious your whole entire life?
Yes, I've been very curious.
That's why you're a good journalist, Emmy.
Is there a story that you would like
for everyone to hear today that you feel is important?
There was this person, he lives in Rexburg.
He made an igloo, they call it the Skittle igloo.
They put pans of ice and then they add food coloring
and they stuck it on the igloo.
They're the [Inaudible].
They put lights in, so it looks really cool at night.
And the dad's a doctor.
So everyday after delivering a baby,
he would get back to working on the igloo.
Okay, Emmy, I just wish you the very best
and I want you to go out there
and keep asking the important questions,
showing the fun things that are happening in life.
And most importantly, would you come back and visit us?
Yeah.
Okay good.
I'm so glad, we need more of Emmy.
The world needs more Emmy.
Thank you so much for coming today.
(upbeat music)